and chat gpt from time to time yes some
resource that helps you create
conversations or yes Yes Yes
definitely even some
online resources like YouTube and others yes ok this
is very interesting because
em yes it is going to be a completely
different approach than lukita's But well  We
each have our ways of course Hello
guys we are in a wonderful city
in the Henki Park in Warsaw and I tell you
one thing I am super excited not only
because I am here but because there is a
very special person with me
called Andy Oli How are we?
my first time in Poland I'm
amazed I'm excited right
luquita enthusiastic is a word in
Spanish that I have added to my vocabulary
thanks to Luca So imagine then
Sandy, can you tell me a little bit
and tell the person
listening to you a little bit about who you are?  what do you do in
life what do I do in life ex vi exist I
don't do much else eh
I am Andy I am Spanish but throughout
my life I have been lucky enough to be able to
live in several countries experience
various cultures and therefore
also learn several languages  I am passionate about
languages ​​and I also have a channel in
which I focus more on life in
Germany and learning
German for
Spanish speakers that is what I do in
life apart from that I try to exist as
I told you okay very well so today from De
what are we going to talk about I don't know tell me you are going to
talk we are going to talk about grammar
we are going to talk about grammar in
languages ​​yes it is true yes because yesterday eh
We had a very long talk of almost 3
hours no How heavy How are you talking
eh of almost 3 hours  talking about
many things, language learning,
the meaning of life, but in
particular what interests you most is
language learning. And then one
thing is that I have my theory about
how to learn grammar, you have your
theory about how to learn or your  approach
And then we talked about that, I don't think
that our approach now we are going to
discover a little more because we
are going to concentrate a lot on that in this
conversation but I think that our
approach is not that different either,
simply that well maybe we give it or
I in my learning  languages ​​I have given
priority to certain things that he Maybe he
has not given priority But well, we
are going to discover it I imagine No how what how what well
eh to grammar no
So when you start you can
tell me for example What happens eh if
you start with  We take a random language,
which is Korean, no,
how
is it, it takes about three days to try to say
year, this word doesn't fit me,
so you were explaining to me yesterday,
what is your way of saying, let's say,
explain to me this year, we didn't start like this,
What does it mean?  añ añ is like the part that
says Hello then J would be like I give you
the welcome I give you the Hello So to
say it in Korean Okay then that
as a beginner is useful for you to know it or not it doesn't matter at all
in fact I
discovered that very long ago  little eh but
at first I had no idea I knew that
Año Jaso is the way to greet and little
else I had not analyzed at all why
but what happens that to me personally eh
Well I am a person who really likes to
know where things come from  things
that I am saying why I am
saying it like that and I am a person who
analyzes those things a lot, so in my
case I think it is the
turning point, not from here is that eh I
love grammar I love
grammar very much  And yes, it is
true that maybe at lower levels it
is not necessary at all. In other words, you do not
need to learn it. Because not,
as Luca often says, it is because
you do not have the structure and you are not as
familiar with the language as  so
that grammar has a meaning or
has a positive impact on your
learning, then Hey, it is true
that I learn from scratch by listening to
reading without caring much about
grammar, but I am one of the people
who, from an earlier point than
other people, I would say.  Yes, I'm starting to
learn grammar because I'm
passionate about grammar. I'm a total
grammar geek. I like it a lot.
And luckily, unfortunately, it
fits me very well. So, I
have a lot of it. In this case, I learn Korean. And I have a lot of grammar in the language.  Head, I
can explain to you all the
grammatical things that I have learned That is,
but obviously it also has its
negative sides that we will get into that
of course, then you just told me that
you learn, let's say you start with input, yes,
you listen, you read, I listen, Leo, I try to
repeat, I am a person who  I also like to
repeat, I go down the street and if
I hear Korean, go ahead, sir, I hear you
say yes, I hear you say,
Oh man, the tree is beautiful. In fact, here,
this is not so much Korea but China, the
park is well known for its also
those structures that  Now let's go there, it
's great. Look, good thing, if I
walk down the street I
hear the tree, it's beautiful. I'm in the
street with all my little shame.
You know, I like to
repeat it a lot and something has happened to me in
Korea that I could tell.  for
repeating things but I like the
input and listening to how
things are said and from a moment from the very
beginning I start repeating and I start
to get it out of me especially for
pronunciation and other spectacular
So let's go a little more in detail
than  You tell me that you listen and read
And how much time passes from the first
moment you start a language to
when you take your grammar book, what
grammar book, for example, with
German, what happened and what happens with
Korean,
if it is a small book, yes  it's a
bigger book you do exercises you read a lot of
grammatical rules what you do when you
underline things what you do ok this is
very interesting because
erm yes it's going to be a
completely different approach than lukita's but
well we each have our ways and
yes from the beginning  I
like it because the first thing that
we have that I think we do wrong in
general when we learn a language is
that we try to cover the maximum number
of possible resources and in Spanish How do you
say in a lot Barca little press little
press they know better than me  I mean, I
'm Spanish, it's been forgotten, it's been
forgotten that a lot of Barca doesn't press, it
could be that a lot of Barca does
n't press, it's just that she doesn't speak Spanish very often.
No, in fact, in the last three
months I've barely spoken at all.  the
Italian So you're doing a
full immersion in Spanish with me yes
total I mean gra thousand for this
because in good
case what was I saying were you
saying that I was asking you
about the grammar books what do you do
in particular What types of books Ah
yes  yes yes yes, the first thing you have
to do is select what
resources you are going to want to use in Stick
to them and stick with those because
what I see for many people is that they
change resources a lot or Oh, I bought
a book, it doesn't work for me.  I like it, I'll buy another one when I
only do three pages, do a little
research, see what books or what
resources are going to help you and what you're going to
like the most, and try to stick with it, that
is, create a routine with those books, with
those podcasts, with that.  Well, that's
the first thing and the second thing is when I have
found the books that I like.
I especially like the books in
which you can learn by yourself. For
example, I would never buy a book that they
use in academies. Why because they
are usually explained in a simple way?  so
that you need a teacher so there are
many things that I learn by myself
without teachers So I will try to make
that book as easy as possible for
me to understand normally these types of
books have texts that you can read from
the texts that you can  listening from
there is very similar in fact to maybe
how you do it but you read the text you
understand the text and then they explain
the grammatical points of the text okay And
from there there are both
writing exercises that then I, well,  I do
spoken ones, I also make them spoken out
loud and that's how I also add a little bit
of spoken practice, eh, that's
what I do and I also try to
create myself, especially in Korean, I try to
create basic conversations that I
'm going to use on a
daily basis, I try  As you can imagine, I
write down the conversations on paper and then I
try to say them out loud but it's
true that Luca was said there,
I'm still not as comfortable as I am as comfortable
as I am with doing that. And of course, very well, let's go, it's essential, it's
essential, we have to talk.  with someone,
some teacher, some person who
has a high level, even if they are
short and very basic conversations,
but you have to learn the language as
soon as possible in your learning, but
returning a little to grammar, I
really like grammar or  I mean, I
can spend everything all day all day
I really like it because I'm in
bed with the gr well not in bed because I
fall asleep But that's true I don't know if it happens to
you but I try to be a little uncomfortable
because that way I don't  I sleep, I'm uncomfortable,
the chairs are uncomfortable or something because if I don't
stay a little relaxed, the fact
is that when it comes to grammar,
I really like it. I make a lot of
grammar notes and the way I
learn it is I make my own  texts in which
grammar is used then I learn the
grammar related to that text and then what
I do with my notes that I
also really liked writing I
love writing everything I learn I
do the like the grammar block
I write What  It's that grammar and then
I write down all the examples in
context so I can learn it a
little better but literally I can
spend hours learning grammar because
I love knowing what I'm saying and
why I'm saying it that way but that
's my brain a little bit I'll give you a
provocative question Oops oops oops oops eh do
you use chat jpt or gpt do you not use
chatp eh Sometimes the internet to look for
grammar rules
Eh yes Yes in fact yes sometimes yes yes yes
because there are times when the books do not
give me the examples that I want  There are times
when the books give me too many examples,
that is, things that I am not going to use.
So I always write down examples
that I can use in my daily life or
that I am going to bring up in
a conversation at some point, but I don't
care.  To say in an example
that the blue bird landed on the back
of the elephant is that
I didn't expect that. And there are
examples like that in books that you say
why do you know? So I do use it.
In fact I have a video on how to use it.
gpt chat to learn languages ​​Ah,
we put that in the discussion, of course, no, but it
is quite useful and yes, it is useful and in
fact, gpt chat also helps me
sometimes to create conversations.
So I write and it answers me,
so you use it sometimes, yes. I
mean.  No Sao what do I do every day but yes yes yes
once a year it doesn't hurt no but on a
daily basis what I usually do most is
listen to the language I do that every
day definitely so listening
It's one of the most important things and
you said that  of the three examples
no no three of creating
meaningful examples the rules of grammar
are learned with patterns that is, individual
patterns The more examples you give your
brain the better exao yes And above all
examples that you go Well that that you are
going to  use it in your day to day life because
hey, the moment you have to
use that language, you will get that
example that you have written or that you have
learned since you have adapted it to your
life, that is, I don't have to write down
things to myself.  If you are a doctor No, because
your examples are going to be completely
different from mine, of course,
any person is going to have
some patterns that they are going to need
to learn certain things that
are going to be useful to you and not to me, so Well, a
bee.  Ah this one doesn't sting a wasp that doesn't
sting that sting that sting you have to know
that I'm terrified they scare me
like she is scared with those
sandflies that were the insects the spiders
I wasps abellas and I don't know what Ah well it
gives me a little  We're going to upload
anyway Eh then eh the
most important information for you who
are listening to us
eh is that it is important to learn
grammar no Ah for me yes no for
us for everyone it is
important but how is it not how you
learn it is the  yes it's it's obviously
I want to make a distinction here and that is
that there are some languages ​​in which perhaps you
don't need it as much and the clearest example
is Italian Spanish that is me
when and I haven't actively learned
Italian but I used to speak Italian and
now when  hey Luca is talking to me, I
can tell you that I understand almost 90
% of everything he says, there are some
words that escape me but I'm not going to
have any problem understanding the
order of the sentence in how he is
conjugating the verbs because  It is a
language extremely similar to mine, you know,
in this case there is no need to
learn grammar, the truth is, maybe there are
a few things like Michi, like Michi,
that Michi, no Michi Michi, I don't know
what the kitten was, but in Italian,
micho micho, something micho. Ah.  micho is that it
was a phrase not one in Italian it is said
Michi Michi that chi is the one that understood
because yesterday we talked about micho and Michi
but she said Michi now no I
say Michi Italian Ah okay we do
n't have that chi in Spanish So it is
something that still costs me that would have to be
learned cl chi in N are two things
two typical features of
Italian grammar which are that it is difficult Fran
exists in French but does not exist in
Spanish exao said with the accent Med
andal andal Okay so in summary
since  what I have understood or understood It
is not eh grammar is important it is
important to know grammar if if you want to
speak well it is not important to choose a
one two three without not overlooking that a lot of
Barca little presses little presses and
then you use let's say you are
passionate animated you like it  sign up for
things and gpt chat from time to time yes
some resource that helps you create
conversations or yes Yes Yes
definitely even some
online resources like YouTube and so on yes anything like
another another
provocative question but it's not provocative it's
okay provocative it's not provocative
for  generate deep discourses about
the meaning of life Wait, I'm going to
finish my previous sentence, I didn't
finish what I was saying is that
for some languages ​​It is logical and normal
that you are not going to need to get
so involved in grammar but
nevertheless I create languages ​​As for  For example,
German, German has a
very different grammatical structure than Spanish, and
if you don't learn it, you won't speak well, and I
think that here
the ambition that you have with
that language, what you want to achieve with
that language, also comes into play.  That you learn more or
less grammar, I explain it to you for myself. I
completely devote myself to
languages. I love learning everything about the
language and that's why I think I also
like grammar so much because I want to
speak it as accurately and as fluently and
natively as possible.  but there are times when this
is not the case in languages. Maybe I
'll start learning another language and say,
Well, I want to talk a little about the street,
I'm not very interested, I won't focus so much
on grammar, so I think that's where it
also comes into play, why do I do it?
whatever your level of involvement is,
what your level of interest is also
Passion with the language I think this all
comes into play but I'm telling you that for
me it is always important because
any language I learn is a high
passion for me and I want to achieve a  high
level so I wanted to make this
distinction very well I also ok it's
important well it's important for me
sometimes some people like to
fumble languages ​​And that's
perfectly understandable it's perfect
but there are people who want to speak a
language very well and grammar is part of it
That's super important to learn
exactly. I
wanted to ask you another question that isn't
provocative but now I don't remember. I
missed it. Wait, wait, I have to
remember what I wanted to tell you. Oh
yes, one thing, one last thing I
wanted to delve into, we do
things like Rajoy.  we don't talk about
politicians here but rajoy is a bit
particular we particularly like G we
have spent more or less two days
talking about
raco In fact if you want to learn
structured sentences that are grammatically correct
logical and semantically correct don't
listen to rajoy listen r don't listen
to rajoy of all  ways What I wanted to say
and when it happens to you that now when you
speak Korean for example you think about
grammar that is when you want to express
something eh It happens to you I tell you because with
Japanese and Korean it is similar in the
sense of syntax and the whole thing is that  One
of the problems I had and I almost
gave up on
Japanese is that if
you focus too much on grammar
then that prevents you from
speaking fluently. At least in
my case and many people have this
problem.  to think about grammar
when you express yourself, you need to make two
distinctions because with Korean it
seems to me something more particular.
So for example, I'm going to start
with German. German is very
necessary, but it's true
that you can speak it.
grammatically incorrect as long as
you say the right words and vocabulary they
will understand you and in fact
Germany is a country or the Germans are
known for doing everything possible to
understand you because when I started
speaking German I spoke like, well, like
Tarzan, not like they say  because like
a Spanish cow Hala no a
Spanish cow that is very ugly Ah no that is
said in
French as Spanish I said it in
Spanish Fran talking to a cow Spanish
says French it is said in Spanish in Spanish
it is said to speak like Tarzan speak like
Tarzan
Spanish Yes, I have also heard that
and the first time I heard it in
French it was like But what, what are you
telling me about us the case also
said in Spanish nothing that is good but there
is a squirrel ien in German by
ardilla no la  I see it's no good no
Look you see it's orange there How beautiful
Ian in German one of the most
complicated words to learn is that I don't
see anything there in that tree but at
the bottom you have to know that without
contact lenses I'm blinder  I'm here
to guide you along the way, don't worry, you're
not going to collide, well, with German,
and I always see him, I mean, I live in
Berlin and I see him often,
and you don't have to speak the language well
to be understood and  so that they can
understand the truth, that is the
truth with German and with many other
languages, you don't need to know that you are
a king of grammar, but what I
was saying, no. There are certain moments in which
grammar for me and in  In general, I think
it is quite important and the thing is that for
example now in Korean, in much of the
grammar what it
has has your emotion implicit,
so if I use a grammar that
has an implicit emotion that
is not the one I want to convey, I am
transmitting something opposite.  I mean, I
could very easily be saying to be
condescending than to be more
receptive to the information you are
giving me, so in that case it is very
important to know the grammar because
you can [ __ ] grandly in Korean
said in silver So in this
case for me  Grammar, when I
speak Korean, I do think a lot about
grammar because I say, my goodness, I
can mess it up a lot. If
I use the one that is not, in this
specific case, it is more important. Of course,
you can learn
basic grammar and speak Korean, no.  There is
no problem, it is when you want to
start putting these
emotions, the feeling that you want to give to the
sentence, which is when the grammar has to
be very clear and right now
when I speak it I think a lot about
grammar
personally. One last very
interesting question, all of that. Then t  I want you to
tell me what you think I don't agree
with you when I don't say anything it means
I have a different view you haven't
said it
perfectly sir
question is it you create
grammar courses or are they like that so they are courses
to teach How to learn
German grammar no eh they are  specific courses
on German grammar and grammar
learned in context in context
so
hey what I do is that when I
learned German I say it again I
love grammar Okay so he didn't
say it in case you hadn't
realized it in case  No, grammar meant I
married her, she could love it. If
Grammar were a man, he would be
perfect, but hey. When I learned
German, it was a problem that I had that I
couldn't find. In my case, I learned it quite a few years ago. I couldn't find
any.  resources that were good at
grammar, yes, you explain well,
especially in Spanish, they explained well in
English, but in Spanish there was nothing in
fact. Eh, you don't have to put this in,
but my channel was the first that
explained German in Spanish, my
YouTube channel.  So eh, there wasn't that
bridge between Spanish and German in
such a simple way, and I
had to learn grammar as best I could on my own with
the resources I could, giving thanks that
I knew English, but of course, if you're thinking about screwing it, there are
many people who don't.  They don't have
access to this because they don't know
English or because they can't. In the end,
I created the grammar courses but done
in such a way that you will always
learn them in context and the important thing is that
another thing that bothers me is
that they divide you  the grammar in I don't know
how many levels that they then tell you is not
that we have learned this grammar in
this at this level and we are going to return to it
in the sixth it does not make any sense to
me it does not make sense so what I
do is learn the grammar  complete and
teach the complete grammar of all
levels what you would learn eh everything you
have to learn from that is there
You know why not a complete course Yes
then well you learn in context I
try to teach like this a little bit in a
more useful way let's say eh I'm going  I'm going to
put all the information about Andy and
his things eh in the description box
I did like this in Spanish des Box in the
description box it's perfect
thank you very much luquita it has been fantastic
a kiss I hope I hope it has
given you something but learn grammar
Cool grammar Cool sure yes please
can you write below what is
your approach your experience with
grammar And tell us what happened
because grammar again It is important to
know grammar but you have to know
how to learn it Thank you very much A
kiss see you soon come  bye
bye